this latest early morning attack
targeted cities across Ukraine with a
barrage of ballistic and cruise missiles
the country's air defenses claim to have
shot down around half of them but
Falling missiles and debris caused
widespread damage and casualties in
residential areas such as here in
Kei Emergency Services responded to
calls in several
districts I was still in my bed and
there was a boom I'm living in this
building it was terrible I was shaking
all
over for the first time since the start
of the war I had to hide it was very
scary Ukraine's Second City harv was
also hit by multiple missile strikes
destroying a number of
homes when the missile attack started I
took cover behind the washing machine
something hit me in the neck I'm alive
but some people
died like ke har has suffered heavy
bombardments in recent weeks air strikes
have been continuing back and forth
throughout the winter with Ukrainian
forces in recent days launching long
range drone strikes as far north as
Russia's Baltic Sea Coast this seems to
be moscow's reminder that it can hit
targets anywhere in Ukraine when the air
raid alarm sounded in keev some
residents took shelter in the subway
system there was a heavy missile attack
on January 2nd our child began to hear
all the explosions and we started to go
to the
subway and once the strikes were over
and the alarm ended people once more
turned to the job of cleaning up Rob
McBride Al jazer
ke make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer